i i don't know where some people
feelings must get hurt easily
tom sure don't you know he's a coach so
i'm a player just trying to win a game
tom brady after 20 years in new england
never being called out publicly by his
head coach bill belichick called out
plenty in the film room
with no one else other than members of
the organization around
a new reality for tom brady but look
here's the thing
peter he can't be surprised about it if
he's paid any attention to bruce arians
over the past 20 years he knows that's
who bruce arians is it's one of the
reasons why bruce aaron didn't get a
head coaching job until 2013.
he doesn't mince words he doesn't kiss
butts he says what he believes
and no offense and you know what uh if
you don't want to get called out
don't stink it's that simple
i really don't think this affects tom
brady
much more than a mosquito on his
shoulder
i just i don't think it's that big a
deal to him
and i think it's easy for us to sit here
and to say wow aryan's calling out brady
but mike you just said exactly what
bruce aryan's career is
he's done it with carson palmer he's
done it with andrew luck he did it with
ben
roethlisberger he's done it with all
these guys
and so i just i can't
take this very seriously
and and and there's one other point
about
what happened in week one of the season
okay
the tampa bay buccaneers who on monday
celebrated their first anniversary their
one month anniversary
of being in a huddle for the first time
with tom brady
played their first game at new orleans
probably the best team in the nfc right
now
and certainly a favorite to win the
division
by a lot and also a favorite to get home
field in the playoffs
so with a coach and a quarterback who've
been together for 15 years
so my only point about all this is
all right the the tampa bay buccaneers
had the toughest game on their schedule
in the first game of the year with tom
brady who just started
six weeks ago throwing to his receivers
in practice
and so i that's why i just basically say
everybody relax here did brady make a
dumb throw that janoris jenkins
returned for a pick six yes he did do
that
i bet you could look at virtually every
game
of tom brady's career and see a dumb
throw
and and again he should have had more
better throws i i get it i totally
understand
this is one game his first game
and his toughest game of the season
comes in that first game so that's why i
think everybody needs to relax
yeah i agree with you completely and it
does get easier now if they don't have
their way with the panthers this weekend
in their home debut then you start to
get concerned because this panthers game
is far from the most difficult on the
schedule for the buccaneers so they need
to start winning games there needs to be
a sense of urgency
and i think they should be fine the only
issue is you've got chris godwin in the
concussion protocol mike evans doing
better this week with a hamstring
problem
and he played well in week one there
were 67 yards of past interference
penalties he drew
if he hadn't been interfered with he
catches the ball brady's numbers look
better the the impression of his
performance
is better and and i think he's going to
go to mike evans more often he was able
to get the ball down
the field to him on a couple of those
occasions it's just that he got
interfered with
or he would have had the catch so i
think that will come
the guy i'm more concerned about is rob
gronkowski
peter i watched all of that game now he
was on the field for 77
of the snaps more than any other tampa
bay tight end
but he was doing a lot of run blocking
and the two catches he had
the first one it looked like he was
running in mud i mean he did not have
the burst he did not have the presence
he did not have that physicality
and and and look he's been off the bike
for a year
that may be the explanation and maybe
the reason he was on the field for 77
percent of the plays is because bruce
aaron's realizes the only way to get
this guy in football shape
but he's got a long way to go and if he
can get there they'll be fine
but he needs to get there
mike you know i saw two days of
bucks practice in august and
what i came away from
those practices thinking especially i
saw the first practice
that they had their offense against
their defense it was a
high energy practice guys on both sides
are really fired up
and here is what i can tell you about
sort of the philosophy and the mindset
of byron leftwich and bruce arians okay
and tom brady right they
were very very set on making oj howard
their reclamation project you know and
he was going to get the ball a lot and
you saw that the other day
okay the other guy and i kept saying
i said man he is throwing a lot to that
little guy from bowling green
and that's scottie miller so
in my opinion when everybody says
oh my god how are you you got so many
weapons how are you going to divide up
the
you know the balls and everything well
right now you're right you have
uh you don't know how healthy evans is
godwin is in the concussion protocol
now you need scotty miller to be
a big factor in this game on sunday
you need o.j howard you know to come out
and play a big game on sunday
so to me i kind of look at that and
again
i i never thought i always thought gronk
was going to be like a 25 snap a game
guy was going to be a red zone guy
uh and and who knows what he'll become
but i was surprised when i saw all the
snaps he played
i think he's going to settle into a role
where he's on the field a little bit
less
but he's always on the field for the
jump balls in the end zone
yeah i agree with you but they did need
him to help for uh with the blocking
because the offensive line is a work in
progress one of the guys who got called
out this week
by bruce arians tackled donovan smith
for having a bad game against the
new orleans to the panthers
the panthers and that's the thing about
week one you never know how good that
team is
that beat you you never know how bad
that team is that you beat
the panthers seem to to give the raiders
a better game than
anyone would have expected and they
scored a lot of points
uh is this just bad raiders defense or
is matt rule the new head coach already
on to something
i i don't think the raiders are gonna
have a very good defense but and it's
definitely a work in progress
because mike i mean you know what mike
mayok
did mike mayok basically drafted
some of the best players in college
football you know
over the last whatever 16 months
and now you got to throw them all
together and see what you got but
it's going to take a while especially
without one
full off season you know for them to be
whatever they are going to be
but i'll say this about the panthers one
of the things and i spent some time with
them virtually
a few weeks ago and one of the things
that really
interested me is that you know
you think that this is like
uh matt roll's first year at temple or
matt rule's first year with baylor
it's gonna be a total uh you know a
two-win
season and we're building for the future
because that's what he did
twice at college programs that were way
down
okay but i don't think they viewed it
exactly this way
this year for a couple of reasons number
one
teddy bridgewater is gonna make you
competitive this
is not a uh well let's
you know let's let's see how good we can
be next year
don't you think teddy bridgewater knows
that if he gets beat up
and he's just okay and they win three
games
don't you think teddy bridgewater knows
they're going to draft trevor lawrence
or
one of these guys you know this year in
the draft of course he does
so he knows that he's got to come out
scratching and clawing
it's just like the dolphins last year
where everybody said well
tanking you know they're gonna tank
vertua and
and what happens is they come out and
after halloween they got a better record
than the patriots
and my whole thing is you never
really know what kind of team you're
going to have
at the start of a season and especially
this
unknown season and and i've always
thought that these panthers
were going to be a little bit better
than people thought just because
teddy bridgewater is playing for his
basically you know his nfl life this
year
and they've got christian mccaffrey it's
easy to forget that we've pegged the
panthers as one of the worst teams in
the nfl
they happen to have the best running
back right now in the nfl and that
counts for something and mccaffrey had a
solid day and
and they kept it close and look just
like the bengals hey they don't want to
only lose by four or five points they
want to win football games
and uh you know the i just think every
win that they manage this year
is gravy for matt rule because it is a
reclamation project
he is in year one and you get the sense
that owner david tepper
understands sometimes you have to take
that step back
in order to build it for the future
and uh but but hey
you know we were stunned last week when
the jaguars beat the colts if somehow
the panthers could pull this off
on sunday and take down the buccaneers
and send tom brady and company to owen
ii that's when you have to completely
reshuffle the deck on your expectations
for the 2020 season peter
mike you know you mentioned david tepper
and let's just remember
one thing okay who's the richest
owner in the nfl right now it's david
tepe
tepper okay and who
went who took a private plane to head
the new york giants
off at the pass to meet uh
to meet matt rule at his home in waco at
the
the night he came back from his family
vacation
and he sits there in his study for four
hours
convincing him don't get on that plane
to new york tomorrow
i want you to be the head coach of this
team so what happens
the next morning at 6 30 he's on david
tepper's plane going to carolina to be
the coach of that team
so and i only mention that because there
are
some owners in this league who you think
well they're tied to their coach
christopher johnson well you know he's
tied to adam gates
well okay after one week he's got to
give him a vote of confidence because
he's got a pile of crap coming down on
him and his franchise
and this coach who he says is a great
offensive coach
so i get it i get it but so some owners
have to say they're behind their coach
okay
this owner is rock solid
behind his coach and is going to give
him every
resource possible to win
so that is an advantage that a lot of
head coaches in this league do not have
nine million dollars a year goes a long
way toward
showing the commitment as well and i
yeah it's amazing to me that david
tepper still fairly new to the nfl
fraternity blows out the coaching salary
curve there have got to be some of the
old guard owners who are
pissed about that because you're going
to have other coaches
established coaches younger coaches
coaches you try to hire
who say i want what matt rule got and
the other owners are just going to have
to suck it up and do it
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports